as an architect uh there's a story
that's been going around it's actually
local to you i don't know if you've
heard about this but um at uc santa
barbara
charlie munger who is warren buffett's
right-hand man billionaire
is building this like high-rise
windowless dorm and i i mean like 13
stories and some like 600 rooms or
something and only five percent of them
have windows so these tiny little dorm
rooms and there's been
this huge
like twitter backlash against it
and uh charlie munger did the most
billionaire thing ever which was to
respond to a twitter feud by calling a
print journalist and wanting to bring
them in to do a story to talk about how
stupid everyone was for opposing the
windowless dorm and to me this just had
conan written all over it because it
sounds like a montgomery burns yes story
lines start to finish yeah yeah it says
well i i i i did work on the simpsons
years ago and my favorite character to
write for was
was mr burns because i love
uh-huh i love a bad guy who's got
limitless funds because yes
the creative comedic options are
limitless and uh so that really makes me
laugh why is does he have a rationale
for why there's going to be no windows
in this door
uh so the idea supposedly it's like his
social experiment which again montgomery
burns all over it but um yeah the idea
is that people don't spend enough times
outside and so if the room is really
tiny and oppressive then people will
spend more time socializing and going
outside and by the way so he's
essentially
he's building a building that people are
going to hate so much they won't want to
be in it and then they're going to go
outside so why not not build the
building and
that's the insane thing to me he's
cooking a meal that no one wants to eat
because he thinks people eat too much so
don't cook the meal right right yeah
yeah
yeah wow and and so mike my question
where my question comes from is i think
you know you guys the chill chums uh you
you know each other pretty well yeah
so if you were going to
design a space for your fellow child
chums
that would be like the almost like the
perfect torture chamber yep you know
what would you put in it you know what
sona what would you put in there for
conan conan what would you do
would it be like
you know would you have a tv that had
netflix but only
you can only watch conan oh yeah well
see you're doing the work for us
i love that i'm thinking i love that
persona it's a it's a 1970s television
it only gets one channel and it's 24 7
me that i think that's
terrific i like that um i like that
there's no kitchen so you can't have any
of your favorite snacks or foods oh um
and uh
i love that i would design it so there
was an echo so that whenever you spoke
it echoed your voice almost as loudly as
you spoke the first time you had to hear
yourself
constantly constantly so that's my
thank you that's done that's good well
mine can i do mine now for you yeah it
would be a room with a window a giant
floor to ceiling window that had no
drapes or any way to shut the window
closed so you have to face the sun
uh also i would also get you a tv that
just played you just so you can hear you
i would do it what you would do to me
that's torture for both of us
because i wouldn't want that either so i
think that's yeah that's perfect
my thought was the same thing a window a
huge floor-to-ceiling window but maybe
there's like an enormous crowd
that's all watching something else like
oh eric you nailed it
nailed it
people walking by and seeing him but not
acknowledging him yeah and then they're
all watching something else they prefer
a different kind of comedy
um well you're an evil genius eric